if you watched your friends get torn
apart by hook like cockroaches what
would you do you've just landed on Mars
which is infested with millions of
human-hating cockroaches they're smart
strong and have better survival skills
than you I'm going to break down the
mistakes made what you should do and how
to beat the mutant cockroaches in
terraformars this kid has no idea that
horrifying alien cockroaches will rip
apart all of his friends soon the world
has been overrun by a terrifying virus
and people are dying left and right
hoping to win the prize money from this
death game akari here needs to pay for
his sick girlfriend's life-saving
surgery or else she'll become another
victim of this disease and he prepares
for his final match just as the reigning
champion of the death matches enters the
ring and over 750-pound black bear
towering over him this bear has been
starved prior to every match and feeds
exclusively on human flesh and the two
fight to the death suddenly akari gets
knocked down and the bear begins tearing
him open and eating him alive all the
while as two mysterious people watch
from a distance but that's when akari's
rage turns him into a terrifying monster
and he brutally tears through this
Bear's eye and crushes its skull killing
this monster and finally winning the
tournament he goes to collect his
winnings but gets stopped by the two
mysterious people watching him and they
reveal to him the worst possible noose
his girlfriend has just died making her
another victim of this worldwide disease
akari here collapses in shock and these
two introduce themselves as commanding
officers komachi and Michelle they work
for a space agency called you NASA and
they tell akari that the virus that
killed his girlfriend came from Mars and
that right now there is no cure at least
on Earth they tell him that they need to
fly to Mars and stop this virus or else
billions more will die thanks to his
unique powers Comanche and Michelle
offer him a spot on the team and akari
Greece to join them to help save the
world so that no one else just like his
girlfriend will have to die later akari
wakes up in a hospital bed and Michelle
tells him that he's been asleep for a
week and that he and many others have
just undergone a terrifying surgery to
help prepare them for the horrors that
they will soon face on Mars this surgery
has given everyone on the team special
powers using a drug they will be able to
temporarily access the powers of certain
animals and bugs that have been infused
into their DNA this Mars mission is more
horrifying than everyone thinks and
everybody gets ready for their mission
brief in order to stop this horrifying
virus from spreading across the world
and killing billions they'll need to
find a cure on Mars however though
there's a catch you NASA has tried going
to Mars before but the team that they
sent 42 years ago almost all of them
died and that's when Michelle tells them
the horrifying reason why 500 years ago
you NASA sent up a group of experimental
cockroaches to help terraform Mars but
now their species has evolved to become
a Ruth worthless killing machine over
seven feet tall three times as fast as a
cheetah and able to lift over 50 times
their body weight these monsters will
kill any human they see and had
decimated the previous team that you
NASA had sent up there the last time
forced to adapt to Mars's harsh
environment the Flesh and Blood of these
terraform are cockroaches are likely the
only thing possible that can cure this
alien virus on Earth but this disease is
spreading and they are running out of
time Michelle tells them that this is
their last chance to save Humanity or
else the human race will soon go extinct
and also because the Earth has become a
little overcrowded in the last few years
okay one second ago I was fighting off
an 800 pound bear to save my now come to
find out dead girlfriend and now I've
been invited to save the world from mass
extinction 500 years ago cockroaches
were sent to Mars along with a bunch of
moss basically for them to feed on the
Moss and then die and then the carcasses
would help the moss grow but Mars's
brutal atmosphere forced them to evolve
over time and now the key to this virus
likely lies on Mars and even more likely
inside of them however there's something
definitely strange going on with this
situation that makes me wonder if there
is something more evil going on with
this safe Humanity Mission because just
like those terraformars akari and the
rest of the team have undergone a
massive change but unlike the
terraforming bugs they didn't have 500
years to perfect the changes the surgery
that they all went through has a less
than 30 percent survival rate except for
this chick Michelle she is the daughter
of a previous Mars crew member from 20
years ago and just like her her father
underwent a version of the bug surgery
and as a result this woman has inherited
her father's powers on top of whatever
power she got from the surgery her
inherited power also can be used at will
and without the use of any serum and the
same goes for akari you NASA discovered
that an individual who inherited a power
has a massively much higher chance of
surviving than normally less than 30
percent chance survival rate surgery
that is why Michelle and komachi went to
akari in the first place that is why she
and him are so valuable so far nobody
else on the planet has been found to
have inherited any powers through the
surgery each team member has been
inserted with the powers of an animal or
bug and these abilities have granted
them enhanced speed strength and
physical endurance with the use of this
specially designed serum this drug can
unlock their full powers for a limited
amount of time and will allow them to
basically become an Unstoppable killing
machine themselves for a limited period
of time which brings up a few questions
for me one at the cost of over 800
million dollars for a single space
flight that is being coordinated with
multiple Global leading Nations this
makes me question as to why they would
only be sending one rocket for such a
supposedly world-saving Mission and this
means that if I was akari I would be
suspicious as hell about this Mission
from the get-go and being the fact that
this agency is a government entity this
means that akari now has just signed his
life away and this means that that
opting out is no longer an option at
this point this kid seems royally
screwed and with little options left I
would work on figuring out more
information about the assessment pool of
candidates their reasons for being here
and the why behind it all where do they
come from are they being treated better
or worse by their government all of
these things will help narrow down if my
suspicion that this whole world
government-saving thing is actually just
a front for something far more Sinister
the group then blasts off to Mars and
everybody gets to know each other
everyone here thinks that they're ready
for the mission but they'll soon regret
that they ever got on to this ship
captain komanchi then updates everyone
that they'll soon be entering Mars's
atmosphere but that's when he notices
one of the security cameras stops
working he thinks something is off and
tells Michelle to go check it out
meanwhile akari and blonde guy wait in
line for the showers but noticed that a
certain person in there is taking too
long suspicious they go to check it out
and also creep on this crewmate but
that's when they see this girl staring
right back at them they try to play it
cool but no us a dead look in her face
suddenly the door bursts open and they
see a terraform are holding this girl's
corpse it tries to smash akari's face
but he Dodges it and tells his friend
here to go get help but suddenly
Michelle arrives and she tells him to go
find and protect their supply of serum
because without that serum everyone here
is dead one by one the alien cockroaches
come out of hiding throughout the ship
and beget to brutally tear Crush stab
rip apart every human being that they
see and they quickly overrun the area
causing widespread Terror and panic
meanwhile akari and blonde guy Sprint to
find the serum but that's when they
discovered that the missions entire
supply of serum has nearly been
destroyed meanwhile komachi tries to
retreat back to Earth but you NASA tells
him that they can't afford to turn back
and that failure is not an option
suddenly an explosion erupts inside of
the ship and it begins to violently come
crashing down into Mars's atmosphere
komachi orders all the recruits to head
to the Escape Vehicles as the top six
officers start killing off the roaches
inside of the ship just as they see from
the window that their entire ship has
become swarm formed and covered with
thousands and thousands of terraform our
monsters okay this just got a lot harder
because right now these people haven't
even landed and are already up shit's
creek they're hurtling down towards
Mars's surface and I'll have a sea of
bugs trying to break in and kill them
all they've already lost the element of
surprise and they've already lost their
Ace in the Hole their supply of syrup
had they been able to land on Mars in a
more low-key fashion that would have
definitely upped their chances of being
able to deal with smaller groups of
terraformers which would have allowed
their Advanced weaponry and superpowers
to be able to kill any alien cockroach
that they saw provided they all stuck
together and or they fought off
microscopic portions of the millions and
millions of cockroaches that live on
Mars and that's not even the worst part
the worst part is that these monsters
already knew about this rocket and this
team's whereabouts even before they
landed and that means that somebody had
to tell these monsters about it in
advance not knowing how these bugs got
onto the ship it's likely that someone
sabotaged the mission which means that
the mole is likely one of the senior
officers on the team being ordered and
controlled by the country or government
agency that is backing them on the
mission if we look carefully all the
senior officers come from different
countries and that means that while
saving the Earth does sound like a cause
that the whole world could get behind
the fact of the matter is is that we
have various countries participating in
this mission that means that we have
many hands in the pot and many conflicts
of interest it's likely that one or more
Nation got greedy and sought to destroy
this mission for a gain of some kind
this also means that Captain komachi
shouldn't have trusted every one of his
senior officers as it's clear that he
gave every one of them almost equal
access to parts of the ship including
the executive wing of the ship if I was
him I would have made a calculative
decision from before the launch and
would have trusted specifically
crewmates from the countries of Japan
America and Germany if I was Captain
komachi I would have placed only select
people I trusted in the most precious
areas of the show namely the cockpit of
the cargo bay where the serum was stored
and the engine area of the ship because
the engine suddenly being destroyed at
that moment was quite a clinky-dink
don't you think and it's noted that the
terraformers have enhanced Evolution
capabilities which means that sending
humans with enhanced capabilities from
the get-go might not have been the
smartest move either because wouldn't it
have been cheaper or even easier to
focus on building machines to fly to
Mars to handle this problem for them why
waste precious human life when you can
just burn through machines the
technology nowadays is incredibly
Advanced so why did they send only
simple drones to Mars and humans instead
and to top it off not all of the powers
are created equal not all of the crew
members were given grade A powers and
that makes them liabilities and
weaknesses within the group if the world
was really trying to save itself why
send only 100 people for a mission that
must succeed why only give people powers
that are weaker than others why don't
they just keep fudging with genetic
material until they're able to produce a
result that gives all 100 crew members
grade A Powers all of this makes me
suspect that this mission was never
meant to really succeed the recruits
rushed to the sixth emergency escape
vehicles and they're led by the officers
to avoid an ambush they'll all land in
different locations and regroup once the
worst is over one by one everyone
escapes the mothership and akari's group
lands safely and they think they're safe
for now but that's when komachi realizes
that thanks to the disaster on the
Mother Ship his whole team only has an
emergency supply left of serums on their
escape vehicle knowing that they're
outnumbered and overpowered komachi
tells his Squad that a rescue team will
arrive on Mars in 40 days to save them
but until then they have three
objectives that they must complete in
order to survive regroup at the
mothership crash the site restore the
research equipment and prepare to return
with samples of the disease knowing they
need help komaji and his Squad go to
find Michelle's group but they suddenly
run into a terraformar and everyone here
realizes that it's an ambush this one
terrified girl manages to capture one of
the aliens and everyone here breathes a
sigh of relief but suddenly the alien
cockroach points its hand at the girl
and blasts the hole right through her
the whole group is shocked at this
alien's new undiscovered powers and the
girl slowly dies in komachi's arms and
he realizes something truly horrifying
this alien has the same Powers as an old
you NASA crew member from a Mars mission
conducted 20 years ago these creatures
have not only killed his old friends but
they have figured out a way to harvest
his dead friend's powers for their own
okay one second I thought I knew who my
enemy was but now I've come to find out
that not only are they a superbug
killing machine but they've somehow
managed to harvest the powers of all the
crew members from the previous Mars
mission and this makes them even more
deadly and even more of a wild card and
this means that this crew here needs to
start thinking of safer ways to conduct
their business rather than simply going
head-to-head with these creatures and
essentially rolling the dice on their
luck and from the beginning these
specially trained soldiers are going
about this thing the wrong way it makes
no sense any longer for this crew to
continue on with their mission right
away to take on this one bug considering
what happened at their Mothership
staying at ground level at this point is
a recipe for disaster If I Was This Crew
I would work on getting to a higher
altitude as high as I possibly can with
the Escape vehicle this will allow us to
accomplish many things at once one we
are smaller and more discreet than the
mother ship and we will be able to cover
more ground more quickly and find
Michelle's group faster using the
sensors on our Escape vehicle and two we
could very well be safer in the higher
levels of Mars's atmosphere we don't
know how high we were in Mars's
atmosphere when the bugs covered the
mothership and remember the terraform
our bug was based off of Earth's
cockroach and that can survive anywhere
except in elevations above 6 500 feet
and where it's too cold even after 500
years of transformation this is a
short-term solution but with it we will
be able to get a breather and be able to
accomplish one more thing and that would
be to find some place safer in order to
be able to send off a message to Earth
and ideally be able to contact them and
tell them outright that someone has
tried to sabotage this ship and and this
Mission and I'd also mentioned that
they've just discovered that these
cockroaches have harvesting abilities
and have acquired the powers of past
crew members this will not only stir up
some controversy back on Earth but at
the very least the rescue team that is
on its way could be a little more
prepared and ready for the hell that is
waiting for them and what komachi just
noticed about this bug harvesting past
crewmates abilities either means that
these monsters either stole the powers
of past crew members sent up here or
someone or some government entity or
country gave them these extra powers and
that means that this team needs to First
figure out who their real enemy is
before they continue going any further
with this Mission the rest of the six
teams all realize at the same time that
these terraformers are smarter than they
thought and they figured out that all of
the you NASA teams have become separated
and know about their backup serums on
their escape Vehicles armies of
terraformers begin to swarm each of the
six groups and all of the team leaders
desperately get ready for the fight of
their lives able to run three times
faster than a cheetah nothing can outrun
these monsters seeing the death of his
childhood best friend on the ship
blonde's Spike hair guy is determined to
kill as many of these bastards as he can
injecting his serum he gains the powers
of the one creature faster than a
terraformer a brown huntsman spider
using the incredibly delicate spider
hairs on his body he manages to Spidey
Sense and Dodge every spider attack and
begins Tang through hordes of alien
cockroaches however for all of the
huntsman spiders incredible ferocity and
power huntsman spider has terrible
stamina and blonde spiky hair guy gets
exhausted quickly making him helpless
against the never-ending hordes of
aliens but out of nowhere komachi comes
in and saves him and orders everyone to
begin quickly collecting samples of
cockroach flesh before more of them
arrive meanwhile Michelle's stranded
group tries to contact the other teams
when they suddenly come across a horde
of aliens just like akari she uses her
inherited powers of the bullet ant
injecting the serum she gains the
additional powers of the blast ant akari
then injects his serum and gains the
powers of the bag were moth giving him
the ability to spin unbreakable threads
of silk and these two brutally tear
apart the flesh off of every alien
cockroach approach that they see
afterwards Michelle decides to go wash
off the blood in a nearby lake but that
was her biggest mistake suddenly akari
notices something coming down from the
sky just as another alien erupts from
the lake Michelle tries to inject more
serum but she gets dragged into the
water before she can do anything akari
tries to grab a hold of her but he's too
late okay this is insane because the
situation here has gotten more
horrifying Michelle right now has just
been grabbed by a diving Beetle
terraformer basically a terraformer with
slightly different abilities belonging
to a type of a real-life diving Beetle
and this bug can store pockets of air
bubbles at the end of their abdomen that
allows them to breathe underwater sort
of like a SCUBA tank and this Beetle
taking the show down Into the Depths
means is a huge problem for her since
these creatures can stay submerged for
more than 10 minutes at a time an
average healthy person can hold their
breath from 90 seconds up to 5 minutes
and this means that despite Michelle's
badassery she is no match for this
terrifying creature out of the six
officers she's unique in that she
possesses two Powers her first Powers
one that she inherited from her father
due to his terraformer operation before
she was born her second power is that of
the blast ant magnified to a human scale
this ant can violently explode by
flexing their abdomen so hard that it
basically bursts at the seams Michelle
can basically do this without dying
herself but without the serum she can't
utilize that power which makes her
pretty much useless right now and to top
it off she can't even activate the first
Power and she can't use her blast and
explosive abilities because the
temperature of the enemy's body and the
surrounding atmosphere around her is too
low because she's in water duh which
brings up my question it doesn't make
sense why she wasn't more careful at the
moment she stepped onto this planet if
she knew the limited extent of her
powers and her weaknesses because after
everything they've seen the Cockroaches
rapid Evolution and seeing water on Mars
one could have put two and two together
and deduced the due to the terraform our
suspected ability to evolve rapidly
seeing water on Mars would likely have
indicated that there was a good chance
that some of the Cockroach species have
evolved to possess underwater
capabilities and thus Michelle should
have taken note of this and have been
way more careful around water from the
get-go if only I had been charged with
Michelle's team I would have done it way
differently I would have ordered her and
akari to stay near The Escape of vehicle
to protect our invaluable supply of
serum and would have left any extra
thirstiness Adventures up to the less
important lackeys that surrounded them
as this would have better preserved the
team overall by protecting their most
viable members everybody watches in
horror as Michelle gets dragged deeper
into the lake while this other cockroach
kidnaps their escape vehicle and tries
to kidnap the rest of the terrified
crewmates quickly reacting a cry swings
up onto the ship and manages to save his
teammates with the help of this bird guy
and he prepares to brutally fight this
creature but suddenly notices that its
legs look eerily similar to one of the
crewmates from the previous Mars mission
meanwhile Michelle fights for her life
deep underwater and she realizes that
due to the pressure she can't use any of
her explosive ant Powers she tries to
quickly lock and immobilize the
Cockroach which causes it to run out of
breathable air minutes pass as she
begins to pass out but suddenly she gets
pulled from the Water by akari realizing
that he tied a thin silk rope onto her
before she went down Ethan knocks the
green cockroach out of the ship just as
he gets an SOS alert coming from officer
Redbeard's crew nearby Michelle then
wakes up with a start akari informs her
Redbeard's signal and they try to
quickly fix the damaged landing gear in
order to take off but that's when she
thinks that something fishy is going on
with the Cockroaches elsewhere
Redbeard's crew begins to get surrounded
by more and more terrifying cockroaches
and the team desperately fights for
their life and they're nearly out of
serum and his team quickly Retreats
inside of these pyramids back in
Michelle's team they finally managed to
fix the landing gear and set of course
to head to the annex one crash site and
she informs one of the other groups
nearby to meet up with them on the way
there team leader Adolf agrees to lead
his team to Michelle's but on the way
there they suddenly get pushed off of
their path by another Escape of vehicle
sliding down into this pit and they
quickly get surrounded by hordes of
aliens they quickly find out that their
engine is now destroyed and the team
realizes that they've just been pushed
into another and Ambush okay this just
got more difficult because right now
this team is backed into a corner and
these monstrous terraformers have this
crew dead to rights Adolf here is
literally the only guy who can save them
and is probably one of the most deadly
officers here thanks to his unique
ability thanks to the nearly life-ending
surgery Adolf acquired the power of the
electric eel and is able to generate
incredibly powerful electric shocks from
his body and is even able to produce a
powerful electromagnetic field capable
of shielding himself and others from
gunfire and ranged attacks if needed
however unlike him not all the crew
members are combat ready or useful and
unfortunately most of everyone here is
about as useless as me without a mic in
short this blonde guy is their only hope
this is a good example of any of how
these guys are completely underprepared
and under supported from their
governments on Earth as most of the crew
and including the people on adolf's team
lack any useful combat abilities they
should have accounted for this and have
been given more easy access Weaponry to
better level the playing field for the
weaker teammates so then they could also
help fight against the terraformars by
relying on a few officers and a meager
handful of combat ready crewmates
compared to the dozens of researchers
and non-combatant individuals this seems
like such an obviously bad idea from the
start that it makes me wonder if even
the government actually wanted this
mission to succeed because even the
method of delivery for the serum seems
lackluster at best as it's noted from
depending on the power certain serums
are delivered in various ways from
injections to inhalations which compared
to the year that this is set in you
would think they would have developed
something more efficient in short these
guys were so underprepared and
under-supported it's disgusting Adolf is
their only hope and he has few options
and none of them are good option one
create a big enough of a distraction
that all the bugs focus on him while the
rest of the crew flees and hopefully
make it to Michelle's team option two
save himself punch a hole in the sea of
bugs and get to Michelle's team he is
more valuable than anybody on his team
the goal is to save all of humanity him
staying alive makes the chances for that
mission to be a success however public
that Prospect is two fighters remain and
they work on getting this ship back
under control while Adolf prepares to
fight the horde of monsters about to
brutally tear them apart his second in
command to this lady thinks that it will
be just another fight but she has no
idea just how wrong she is injecting her
serum she charges at this cockroach
ready to kick ass but suddenly gets torn
in half her limp corpse terrifies the
rest of the crew members and they look
to Adolf as their last hope and quickly
begins Gathering piles and piles of dead
terraformer cockroaches using his
electric eel Powers with Incredible
accuracy and skill he's Unstoppable but
then he notices a space car show up on
the hill relieved he thinks it's a
rescue squad but he realizes that
something's very wrong no teammates are
coming to rescue that the leader of the
terraformar army steps out of the car
and he orders his army to attack in full
force he quickly begins to get
overwhelmed as his useless teammates try
to help him out but they get
pathetically murdered in seconds out of
options Adolf does the unthinkable and
injects himself with a second round of
serum unleashing his full power and he
gives his last battle everything he's
got killing everything in sight he
finally gets a shot at the Cockroach
leader and summons a bolt of lightning
down on him finally killing the leader
of these terrifying monsters now barely
clinging to his life Adolf collapses and
thinks that he managed to save his
teammates from certain death but he
doesn't realize just how wrong he is he
is the terraform our leader is revived
by his minions and Adolf realizes that
he's now truly out of options he jumps
in front of this girl shielding her body
with his from the deadly attacks and
barrage of rocks that are being thrown
their way and he finally dies right in
front of her horrified at the death of
her Captain she tries to stop the
Cockroach leader from killing the rest
of the squad but that's when they hear a
horrifying sound the last sound that
they'll all ever hear the terraformer
suddenly retreat at the sound coming
from inside of adolf's body and they
realize what that sound really is the
girl cradles her team leader and close
friend at a huge blast erupts into the
sky akari's group spots the Blast From a
Distance and realized what just happened
everyone on adolf's team has just died
meanwhile Captain komachi's group
continues to fight with everything
they've got and they bring out their
next greatest tactic this green arm guy
to carry the team he channels the power
of the mantis shrimp and Strikes with
the power of a 22 caliber rifle brutally
killing dozens of these monsters 50
times faster than the blink of an eye
this alien cockroach tries to strike but
he uses the Mantis shrimps infrared and
Ultra Violet sensing eyes and he manages
to dodge every strike from this Buck
finally taking it down with a pierced
blow to the chest near him kamachi just
defeats his 104th terraformer of the day
and they think that they finally begun
to turn the tide against these things
but they all suddenly have a horrifying
realization these monsters have seized a
horrifying weapon the fuel supply to
return to Earth looking up into the sky
he sees a missile come striking down and
it explodes around everyone shocked
somehow they think they've made it out
alive but they suddenly noticed
something even more terrifying they've
run out of syrup this guy warns the rest
of the crew that they need to retreat
now but all of a sudden he gets brutally
ripped to shreds and the survivors come
across another terraform arm but this
one is completely different and this one
will cost the lives of almost everyone
here quickly getting overrun everybody
gets killed and gutted blonde
spiky-haired guy here now without any
powers gets cornered and prepares to die
with his comrades as well while kamachi
and green arm guy tried to find a way
out of this hell meanwhile Redbeard's
crew begins searching the pyramids for
ancient alien technology but then they
noticed something strange no no
horrifying monsters have tried to follow
them inside of here and everything has
suddenly become too quiet they discover
an old unmanned you NASA space shuttle
dating back 100 years along with
blueprints for the new NASA alien bug
project already here on Mars and they
all shockingly realize that someone on
their team has betrayed them back
outside blonde spiky hair guy prepares
to die and he suddenly gets saved by a
teammate's fastball and he manages to
cleverly deliver him a new vial of serum
allowing him to reactivate his powers
and giving him one more fight Michelle
and akari's crew finally arrive but
noticed the same strange terraformer
that looks different than the rest and
Michelle prepares to take it down but
then she finally notices what this bug
terraformer truly is the rainbow stag
beetle okay looks like a car's group is
now more screwed than they've ever been
at this point these terraform are
bastards have these space soldiers
cornered and are about to die but there
is one move that I think they could pull
and while it may technically count as
cheating it could work well enough to
get them the hell out of Dodge at least
for now because while we're more
focusing on the good guys the Dream Team
over here this isn't the only crew Left
Alive if we remember Redbeard's crew is
still missing and team China off being
little suspects because everything up
until now has gone majorly wrong for Our
Heroes but if we put on our Sherlock and
like I mentioned before and from the
looks of things there seems to be fewer
people present right now and if we
remember Earlier Bird guy was seeing
carrying way more people to safety with
the help of akari's silk rope which
means that the total weight of all these
crew members should not exceed his
strength limitations at least based on
one we've seen and out of the three
suspicious teams that are located
somewhere else on this planet we can
gamble that these guys fly to team
Russia's location is their best bet in
staying alive at least for now while
fighting this hulk-like disco globe of a
terraformar Michelle realizes that it
has an incredibly durable exoskeleton
and insane amount of crushing strength
this terraformer possesses a reflective
exoskeleton that reflects light around
the surface of its body allowing it to
blend in with the colorful Flames behind
it and Michelle realizes that this
rocket wasn't meant to harm them but to
mask this terrifying terraformar and to
make everyone hear helpless as hell
injured muscles guy over here then tries
to help find this terraformer and takes
a hit of serum using his echolocation he
searches for the rainbow stag monster
and realizes that it's right behind them
Michelle quickly Shields him from
certain death and overpowers and killing
it for good but the battle isn't over
meanwhile Captain Camanche gives the
rest of his team their millionth pep
talk for the day as him green arm Guy
Bird guy and blonde spiky hair guy
prepare for the final round of this
earth-saving fight he tells his team
that they have 39 more days until their
rescue ship arrives but he doesn't
realize that it will never come
meanwhile back on Earth not knowing if
the Mars crew was dead or alive and
unable to contact any of the crew you
NASA never sent to the rescue vehicle
something is blocking all communication
and Japan's prime minister finally
suspects that someone on the team might
be sabotaging the mission on purpose or
a fight this guy tries to plan you
NASA's next move all the while as Mars's
crew continues to fight for their lives
killing hordes and hordes of
never-ending human killing machines hey
thank you so much for watching the video
don't forget to like subscribe leave a
comment down below and as always don't
forget to check out our how to beat
playlist